in die hauptstadt der ukraine russische
panzer parade mitten in der hauptstadt
auf dem majdan
russische panzer aber keine stolze putin
parade sondern eine parade der
russischen verluste das ist sozusagen
die kriegsbeute der ukraine und
mittendrin steht unser bild reporter
paul ronzheimer paul ich grüße dich hält
dass die moral hoch dort in der ukraine
in kiew
die acai das hält die moral hoch denn
man sieht wenn wir hier einfach mal
drauf schauen das sind panzer die auch
viel gesehen haben in den wintermonaten
in ihre pin gutschein den orten die so
heftig umkämpft waren das sind sowohl
kanzler das sind sowohl
artilleriegeschosse all das was auf die
ukraine gefeiert wurde und wenn wir uns
hier umschauen schon gestern waren
tausende hier und haben sich das
angeschaut was das monströse panzer
monströse artillerie fahrzeuge waren mit
denen die russen hier die ukraine
angegriffen haben und für viele wird das
erste mal deutlich wie mächtig und wie
hart die russen hier die ukraine
angegriffen haben wir gehen noch ein
stück weiter das ist hier der platz der
sozusagen genutzt wurde während des
mains carré das muss man vielleicht
erklären hier waren hunderttausende
leute
2013/2014 und jetzt nutzt man das so zu
sagen hier als parade aber nicht im
sinne wie die russen sie wollten sondern
als parade als symbol dafür wie die
ukraine hier diesem krieg zumindest um
kiew stand jetzt gewonnen haben
das sind ihre bilder muss man sagen paul
dort aus dem sonnenschein in der kriegs
hauptstadt wo viele menschen auf der
straße sind sich diese riesigen panzer
jetzt auch ansehen wir sind hinter der
kinder rumspringen und der krieg ist so
nah und gleichzeitig auch doch so fern
[Musik]